Karnes against humanity is a famous game
for being offensive so if you're easily
offended then don't watch this video
Heath Ledger has aged
in cards against humanity' each round a
black card is presented on this black
card it says an unfinished sentence your
job is to complete the sentence with
your white cards the funniest sentence
wins in a thousand years when paper
money is but a distant memory blank
would be our currency [ __ ] I found it
and Frank doing a striptease [ __ ] I find
a good grammar [ __ ] fine flavored new
Disney Channel original movie Hannah
Montana struggles with blank for the
first time struggles with coughing into
a vagina for the first time struggles
with tentacle porn for the first time
with three big feet of pleasure for the
first time oh these are good Holly's
like all the same part of a single story
game from scarred three big feet of
pleasure the game runs it says GG oh oh
oh I gotta go with that one well then
hey salads got one he did it on the
scoreboard yeah thank you
this time on guest rooms we have revenge
cooking we have okay I couldn't complete
my homework because I'm throwing a
virgin into a volcano
could you see my homeboy girls acronym
mr. mate for feeding a dinosaur I
dinosaurs are funny yeah all right guys
use your blink use your wave
again man Mika's fine mom she thought
about stranger danger he thought about
some goddamn peace and quiet like I've
one selected I'm clicking ready click
confirm no no bye boys he's coming back
no I didn't get pic no don't slow down
and eat Cleveland or global these don't
make sense global warming
he's very psychology go up a water
Megan's Kluber warming is it no no you
don't know he may be reverse psychology
lies couples shown technology Oh Jack
this [ __ ] they're so hard punch a bull
Major League Baseball has banned plank
for giving players an unfair advantage
but they've banned dead babies right
right out of the gate with dead babies
Rush Limbaugh's soft shitty body I I
gotta go with this just cuz its are you
[ __ ] kidding me right now babies
babies always wins what gives me
uncontrollable gas used panty vending
machines masturbating over asuka's
comatose body
oh my collection of high-tech sex toys
well from anime that's from Evangelion I
believe yeah it seemed ready to girl
yeah and then the use panty vending
machines that's just something Japan
does for mature Malheur case of a
circuit [ __ ] living inside your test
yes testes testicles that's Dennis oh he
might just save the universe if he only
had some what's up lexing suplexing it's
not on my card I'm just curious it's
like the move and wrestling really lifts
them out over your head that's if it is
suplexing
if you pick suplexing I'm not gonna pick
that he might seize the universe if only
he had some suplexing your teacher
feeling horny aged some rapping samurai
I mean the others just don't make sense
rapping samurai makes sense it does if
only he had a bunch of rapping samurai
it makes sense you guys don't think what
is more
Hey really tell me what is my what are
we gonna tell you mark delay wearing
panties on head I believe that blank the
probably that Zoo having black male sex
with your teacher these are all anime
every single one of this is an amazing
you know we should right answer is Marco
no I don't what are you talking about
the middle one now on that search deep
inside
so you're saying inside a pair of
panties yeah okay I gotta get all Oh
epic for like the anime that's a big
buildup behold the name my zanpakuto is
1,000 years of pay Walpurgis night I
like this word I rather not knowing what
it is you'll never know which one is
mine has a man dick or is it an old man
dragon hybrid dick or what a big
colossal piece okay alright now that
we're clear the Tama skimmed commence a
Parisian it's you feel a spot-on
impression of you alright pose our frat
house is condemned and all the hot slam
pieces are over a gamma for height the
time has come to commence operation
consensual sex operators operation
sniffing glue
I think I know who I'm gonna make win
what do you decide oh yeah I know I
think I know who wanted him is I don't
know who the others there I know the
horse one is wait who's the first one I
think the first one is mark second one
is kin of the last of his feelings
why why and why would you think that
yeah why would you think that yeah I
appreciate the idea you wanted me to win
but goddamnit didn't want you to win who
did you what you didn't want any way to
win did you you just know I wanted me to
wait